I want you to remember don't draw this
but I want you to recall that we did
something similar to this before I'll
just do it small over here right when we
were comparing linear graphs you
remember linea graphs the straight line
winds right so like was X and do you
remember i said what happens if you slap
a number in front of their right like
saying y equals 5x do you remember we
did this ground we had a whole bunch of
different ones we had 5 X 10 X minus 3x
all kinds of different ones these two
the difference is that it will be
steeper ok you slap a number at the
front it's like this one but it's five
times deeper it's like a hill that's
five times harder to climb okay that's
that's the difference between these two
where was the fire be like on the great
movie fired I mean like yeah okay so the
way that I would say is if I've got a
point like PR 11 because I happen to
know that that graph passes through that
point then there would be a point five
times higher up here 15 now the X will
be the same yes but first yeah okay so
you can see it's five times bigger if I
went over it would be up at ten and then
15 and are so many why would be five and
then it would be like normal unless yeah
that's right so if i put in the same x
value to this and this then the wise
will be different but why is it we five
time to be gone yeah 3a and three meters
a 5x or five times 5x squared R it's in
your book a bit of it okay now therefore
i'm going to use this is my comparison
right if you take this and you slap a
fight at the front it gets it gets um
steeper okay well if you take this and
you slap a 5 out front what would you
expect would happen bacon it'll be that
shape but steeper now will do will do
this side first okay see you like all
right it's a it's increasing faster like
that right well on this side you'll get
exactly the same thing but it's
symmetrical remember we have a look at
the palindrome thing before okay so this
is y equals 5x squared it's still going
to have the same shape but Steve I'm
like sir okay same shape narrower if you
like same idea okay now now maybe you
can see why I'm going to put this one on
the same rap right 5x squared it's
steeper a third X square it's going to
be it's going to be fatter isn't it
right just like if I put a third X on
here it would be shallow up alright so
so yeah it's gained a bit away okay so
if I am if I draw out like this okay
that's what a third x squared will look
like okay yeah kind of I know but the
proportions are different the
proportions are different it's the same
shape but it's being squashed down it'll
be a third the height everywhere does
any one minute pause explain any other
ideas on this yeah yeah sure ok I'll do
it from another point of view okay draw
up a little table values with me um I'm
going to get rid of this one because
because I don't need this space okay
we're going to do a bit of a arm a
beefed-up table value want you to follow
along with me okay we used to have just
done just two rows okay there's someone
gonna have a few more
will do for rose okay for us and you'll
need six columns like so
okay hopefully if I show you a different
way it'll help you understand it a bit
different I please thank reason okay you
always gonna have another way up your
pocket all right here's what we're gonna
do we've done tables of values before
right yes ways that x or x the next
night so you've got your ex Rory on with
hot he right here are my values for X
I'm just to try out for values now I
want to compare these three graphs this
time I'm going to compare the numbers
right I try to avoid doing this because
it's slow it takes a long time but once
you see the numbers and we can just
crunch it up with a calculator it's hard
to argue with whereas this is kind of a
bit into a different if you don't get it
why don't I get it I don't know so let's
try this out first I'm going to the
middle row this is y equals x squared we
did this before you've drawn these
values out already right and you can do
with me right now minus two x minus 2
that's y equals x squared well that's
for negative 1 times negative 1 that's
the negatives cancel you just get 10 x 0
0 and then 1 and then for okay remember
this familiar okay all right now let's
go up to this room okay this is like y
equals x squared but i'm multiplying by
5 every number here i'm going to
multiply by fire okay so 4 times 5 21
times 5 550 x 50 all right then five and
then 20 same symmetry way right way oh
yeah if you like oh I by five right all
of these values to get up here I'm x 5
right or you can think about a is 5
times x squared if X is 2 it's 5 times 2
squared what's 2 squared
it's 45 times for its 20 so notice they
they all pass through zero right okay
both places here but these guys are
higher in much higher there five times
fire all right now down here okay from x
squared i'm going to divide everything
by 3 so 4/3 that's four thirds what's
four thirds is a mixed new room it'll be
one and a third one and a third one / 30
/ 30 and then it's symmetrical so this
was the shape we've began with right in
the middle PR and then we compared 5x
squared is the same shape same symmetry
just everything's higher right and then
this one is the same shape just
everything's lower okay if you like it's
like it's like it's the same shape but
something's holding on to it it's
dragonglass we don't that so this these
are all the values that correspond to
this graph with these grafts we're going
to draw a graph right here in a second
can you predict what's the first thing I
like to draw out why why it goes X
square head good okay I'm predictable
right so you might have noticed by the
way this is the way I do it when I do it
free here when I don't have that
template stencil type thing rather than
calm down I usually more frequently I'll
start from the middle and go up and then
start from the middle again and go the
other way I tend to get better symmetry
it's not perfect but like what what I do
the other way and I come down I often
like I miss another like I'll break you
know at least this way and remember it
the turning point the vertex it's the
most important point that's the one you
got to get right so that's that's how I
do it okay so what we going to compare
with this time is this okay
hmm the only difference is I've put a
minus sign on the front so it's minus
question that's sketchy so that's tricky
okay so I want you to guess for yourself
and I'm just share but what do you think
it would look like and then and then my
next question is well how would you then
work out whether you were right where
your guess was right or wrong what are
you recognize it was questioned for a
fire by think but I'm making up a
question which is like question five
okay like as it moved down here okay all
right so here's what I'm gonna do okay
you don't have to follow along with this
but um I'm going to draw up a table
values just so you can see and we can do
it together ok so I'm Jordanian okay why
I'll exercise and what of chuck in some
values I always chuck in these same ones
because they give you a good idea of
what's happening let's do it one at a
time okay let's start in the middle
because they're easy 00 what happens
when you put x equals 0 into this y
equals minus 0 squared minus 0 that's 0
what it is- sir there's a minus that you
can't just forget about it right okay
let's try the next one when x equals 1
when x equals 1 y equals y minus 1
squared and be careful it's um this this
right that's what we got now is
different to this right yes okay so the
difference between these two is the
difference between these two is here
you've got a minus sign and it gets
squared here you square first and then
you slap a minus sign on the front so
it's a bit different for all of our
operations and you should be careful so
now let's try it again this is not what
we've got let's get where that sounds
like confusing when x is equal to 1 y
equals minus
one squared which we might one okay x
equals 2 it's going to be minus 4 you
see why I'll do the numbers for you
right let's let's take let's take 2 y
equals minus and everywhere I see an X
I'll put it to now there's no brackets
here I'm not squaring the negative sign
the negative sign comes in later it's
minus 2 squared right 2 times 2 which is
minus 4 ok so that's why as Nathan said
2-4 over here now all our parabola so
far they've all been symmetrical so if
these are those you've got on the right
what do you expect to happen on the left
it's the same but but in reverse order
right so you can get negative 1 and
negative so have a look at these numbers
they're all with the exception of this
one they're all negative where are the
negative Y values why that is up down
right so negative Y values are they're
all down the bottom this is the shape
you get you get this shape upside down
yeah kind of kind of like an hour zone
ok so this minus sign here it flips the
whole shape upside down ok so that's
what you get